I really enjoyed Disney's live-action
Beauty and the Beast and I loved the way
it even acknowledged and fix some
potholes and mistakes from the original
animated movie but hidden in the new
movie is another bunch of new mistakes
yippie Kay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm going to break
down all the movie mistakes goofs and
plot holes I spotted in Disney's 2017
Beauty and the Beast and if you'd like a
chance to win this beautiful hardback
book tale as old as time the art and
making of Beauty and the Beast all you
need to do is subscribe and leave a
comment about the movie and also answer
the question I'll be asking later in the
video quick warning there are some
spoilers ahead if you haven't seen the
film the movies remake of the opening
song Belle is a lot of fun but it still
has its share of continuity and logic
errors the sources are something rather
wrong with the town clock bells
as they ring seven of the eight bells
before the clock is even struck eight
now look carefully at the double loop of
rope around the horse's face which is
Belle's hands to massage on magically
becomes a single loop next Bell goes
over to Jean and out of thin air appears
to conjure an apple which he gives to
his donkey however if you look at
Belle's skirt as she leaves there
doesn't appear to be a pocket on the
right-hand side of her dress where the
Apple seemed to come from and the knot
tied around Monsieur Jean John Keith
also changes when going from this wide
shot to a close up shot of Belle feeding
him the Apple now keep your eye on the
baguette Belle bought from the Baker
which she put in her skirt pocket
because as we get to the next scene
whoops the bread is gone this particular
mistake might be explained by a scene
which was deleted from the final movie
in which Belle gives the beggar woman
Agatha aka B enchantress a loaf of bread
and a pot of jam unfortunately though
even taking into account that deleted
scene this is still a mistake because
the baguette still disappears too early
in the song for example here were Belle
buys the jam which she gives to Agatha
with the bread and the deleted scene the
bread is already missing I don't know
maybe Marie stole the baguette in
protests at not getting a mention in the
new movies opening song Belle's curse is
also a source of more continuity errors
notice when she starts the song Belle
her skirt is hitched up on her right
hand side revealing some of the white
petticoat underneath the skirt stays
hitched up through the song until Belle
enters the priests library where it's
suddenly down as she entered the library
her hand did seem to move towards her
skirt but that was the opposite side of
where the skirt was hitched up and I
suspect she was just reaching into one
of her skirt pocket for the book she
mentioned she was returning to para
birth there's a funny moment when Gaston
horse kicks mud all over the three
lasses ruining their pink dresses
however when the foo goes over to tell
them it's never going to happen ladies
some of the mud stains seem to have
miraculously disappeared Maurice and
Belle's horse Philippe is also at the
center of several mistakes in the movie
the first one occurs when Maurice is
attacked by the wolves and Philippe
bolts with his harness and chains still
attached
but when Philippe returns to save
Maurice just before the world's guess
he no longer has them next after Maurice
is captured by beasts at the enchanted
castle
Felipe's gets away and runs back home to
Belle arriving dirty and muddy Belle
understands something has happened and
tells Philippe to take her to her father
except that when we see Belle riding
Philippe is clean again it seems very
unlikely Belle would have stopped to
clean to leave and she was rushing to
look for her missing father later when
Maurice leaves the castle we don't see
how he gets back to the town Philippe is
still at the castle when Belle flees and
gets attacked by the wolf so maurice
didn't take philippe with him in the
original animation maurice was sent back
on an enchanted carriage but in the
live-action remake his return to town
remains a mystery when Belle arrives at
the castle she runs up a staircase in a
clockwise direction notice how she's
holding the candlestick in her right
hand which is closest to the inside wall
of the stairs however as she emerges at
the top of the staircase her right hand
and candlestick are closest to the
outside wall and she's now running
anti-clockwise back in town Gaston gets
to perform his big number but just as
the foo start singing gasps dawn's knife
handling reveals a continuity error
watch carefully how his right hand moves
from the hilt of the knife in this shot
to all the way down the blade near the
tip when the foo is singing and the shot
changes angle also during the song
Gaston shoots into the ceiling and a
small pile of debris falls down the song
then continues but from this camera
angle the debris is no longer there the
live-action version of be our guest is
just fantastic yet there are still a
couple of mistakes in there the
guillotine based joke that Lumiere makes
when he chops baguette is anachronistic
as the guillotine wasn't common in
France until the late 18th century
whereas the movie is actually set in the
mid 18th century although the blade in
the film is a bread guillotine Lumiere
says this is France as he chops the
bread and the guillotine is of course
closely associated with the French
Revolution all through the chopped'
forget peace falls into a little basket
similar to how heads did after
executions and on the menu there's
another French flip up with the potato
dishes with a spelling mistake on pommes
de terre where Terre is spelled
incorrectly with an S on the end
and when Lumia introduces the dishes he
mentions various plates that are
supposed to appear on Belle's menu
including beef ragout Cheese Souffle pie
and pudding on flambe except that Cheese
Souffle
isn't actually on that menu it's Cal
Berkeley yay
when Belen Beiste go for a walk in the
castle ground she recites a line from a
poem called a crystal forest which goes
as follows each blade of grass seems
clad miraculously with glass that poem
was penned by a Scottish writer called
William sharp who is born in 1855 and
died in 1905 however as this movie is
set in the mid 1700s
there's no way Belle could have known a
poem which hadn't been written yet the
owl we see with Agatha issues nursing
Maurice gives a little hoot however the
type of owl is actually a barn owl and
barn owls make screeching type noises
rather than the typical hoots you might
expect from other types of owls after
Bella Marie's break out of the asylum
wagon Bell rides off to the castle
dumping her yellow dress as she leaves
she's obviously in a hurry as she knows
beast is in danger but during the ride
back to the castle she somehow acquires
a sweater which doesn't quite make sense
because she got rid of it later anyway
and surely she wouldn't have taken the
time to go home and pick up something
new to work so what are the movie
mistakes
goosal plot holes did you spot in Beauty
and the Beast and how do you think the
movie compared with the original
animation to enter the giveaway for this
gorgeous hardback book tale as old as
time the art and making of Beauty and
the Beast make sure you're a subscriber
and leave a comment about the movie and
also answer the following question what
dish did Lumiere sing about Envy our
guest that didn't appear on Belle's menu
if you enjoyed this video don't forget
to give it a thumbs up and why not take
a look at these ten movie mistakes at
the new Beauty and the Beast fixed from
the animated classic for more of my
other Disney videos below thanks for
watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers